huh  come on oh dear you're a hawkeye who the  hell are you  where escape yourself who are you  talking about  [Music]  why is there an avenger in my dining  room he's my partner  we're not partners ready  blah blah blah blah she always like this  all right friends slash partners i would  describe this as friends  put your phone number in here for  emergencies only  this is goodbye call you later no please  don't  [Music]  just so i can hear you what happened uh  too hard to tell  surprise you know it should be a lot  easier if we were facing right you were  facing the other way yeah just  hey we're communicating  [Music]  help  [Music]  block delete we're at a regular arrow  what do you mean oh my god trick arrows  definitely not this one all right you  don't have to say definitely like that  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  i was doing fine  incoming  [Music]  not bad kid not bad  [Music]  you